hey everybody and welcome to the amazing
Las Vegas Comic Con I am so pleased to
spend the weekend with you you guys are
the comic fans okay guys this is the
seventh this is lucky number seven that
we've been in Las Vegas I'm curious who
was that who was here
that went out to the very first amazing
Las Vegas Comic Con alright let's hear
it this was a you guys are the south
pointers you know you guys have seen it
go from a little tiny event growing and
growing and growing each year and it's
because of you guys and spreading the
word to this Las Vegas fan community
that truly is second to none so I want
to thank you guys for being out here
because I think that we have special
events at the amazing Las Vegas Comic
Con that we celebrate pop culture and
man I dug I dug the MCU and the Avengers
endgame and the infinity war did you
guys yeah absolutely absolutely but you
know what something that that we got to
think about is that there's no easy
button then you just pop down and all
these characters come on out and these
stories come on out I mean you know what
it's not you know what it's not done in
a snap okay but then it all comes from
creators and I think it's important that
you guys see the secret origins or not
so secret origins of the favorite
storylines that you dig that inspire the
movies that inspire the gear that you
wear that inspire the video games that
you play and that's why the creators
matter that's why we keep on saying the
architects of pop culture because these
guys create the worlds that we love
these are the dreamers these are the
architects and to talk this to we have a
special presentation and this is going
to be moderated by Collider we love
Collider they are at a a top pop culture
destination on the internet whether
you're checking them out on YouTube
whether you're following them on social
media
check it out their sites every day go to
collider.com
and from Collider we have koi jondor Oh
koi once you come on out and once you
tell some of the fans who we got here
today how's it going guys so before I
even bring these Titans out I have to
say you guys
killed it with the buying of comics
because I just spent the last hour at
every single and all of the Infinity
Gauntlet number ones are gone excellent
work you did it
so I am bringing out some of my favorite
creators of all time I cannot believe I
get to do this it is an absolute honor I
want to bring out mr. George Perez
[Applause]
[Music]
next up we've got Joseph Rubinstein
we've got mr. Ron Lim
[Applause]
and last but not least jim Starlin
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
so since I've spoke with you gentlemen
last a movie came out called endgame and
I've got to start there like a snap it
just came out so watching in game the
first time and that movie being based on
not a direct property but on characters
you all know more than anyone what was
the first impression of that film and
that in the chances it took and the bold
choices Jim we'll start with you how was
your first impression with the insanity
of a time heist I kept waiting for about
a half hour into the movie where the
really important stuff happened this is
a therapy session but I patiently waited
through it looks so familiar that's
silly
no I've loved it from the moment it
started I was very worried on the first
one in the infinity war because
different reasons but like tooth like
ten seconds into it even before the Hulk
gets beat up I went nothing to worry
about
if you run your first impression of
endgame like though just to scope your
beard away from the comics so I have no
idea where I was gonna go so yeah I just
love the way it turned out
yeah George said you like it I've yet to
see it vanish did it to the crowds not
Joe how'd you like it can you hear me
yeah um I loved it and about an hour and
a half into it they went oh yeah we have
supérieures we should start beating each
other up right but Jim when you did you
immortal line was it more Stella Adler
or what about what
or Meisner I just wondered the acting
discipline yeah written down at the time
so I didn't have to really think too
much about it and only blew one take
could we get you to do it again what
about you thank you
nailed it Stanislav ski method he's got
it an actor prepared get it out so when
you were writing these comics it was a
very different time in comics and comic
books were not white this was it an
interesting a moment the first time you
were watching TV and Ana Spanos
commercial pumped up because for me
infinity war was you know Thanos movie
and my grandma knows who thinness is now
was it was it a surreal experience when
it wasn't like at a Comic Con it was
just on TV well it was just after a
comic-con and I had just gotten home
it was shortly after the infinity war
came out and I thought okay this has
passed you know get back to my real life
I went outside took a leak came back in
watch the recorded version at Late Show
with Stephen Colbert and he does a fan
of joke and I go this is gonna last a
little bit longer than I expected oh man
I thought when I saw the Geico gecko
with the Infinity Gauntlet I said oh god
yeah yeah that's a way to savings I have
to watch more broadcast TV what was the
moment you all new comics switched from
being a subculture to a culture was
there a moment in like the 70s 80s 90s
when you realized the this is about his
mainstream as it gets
well for me it was the premiere of the
Avengers movie or if the first one had
come out and that credits come out at
the end and all throughout the movie
there's been these two guys behind me
one was a comic book fan the other one
was a cartoon fan and soon as Thanos
appears the comic book pangos Adams and
then the cartoon fan goes whose fan oohs
I said that for next year or so just
gonna get a little weird yeah for you
run just when people in general know
yeah it's just really weird coming
generally comics fans right but now it's
like everybody knows who he is which is
pretty cool yeah people starting to ask
for Adam warlock has been weird for me
when like I look at day to day person
being like what do we get out of warlock
how did you know that name
I mean for me one of the things that you
know I realize that how much kind of
broader word subtly when you tell a
person that you're to draw comics they
don't they don't immediately think that
you're doing the comic strips or you say
I do have no do you your comedian
when you say you're combating senators
oh my god suddenly we're treated like
you look like rock stars you know and
thanks to social media
we're recognized and suddenly we've got
the cool job the nerds have the dirt
inherited the earth the geeks have won
you know that's wonderful you know you
know when you tell somebody you're a
comic book artist they're never quite
sure if that means you have money or not
that now that they do it do you get a
share of the movie and I'm always very
happy to say yeah thank ya right but see
ya I pulled up a dump truck and just
dumped a part of a cash on my driveway
but but I'm the next level down because
when I say I'm a comic book anchor they
go the colors no I'm a tracer that whole
chasing amy conversation just comes
right back yeah now I for my money this
is the biggest franchise of all time it
ran 22 movies 11 years of buildup and it
culminated in a property that you all
were responsible for I can't imagine the
scope of waking up and being like oh I
invented Disney 3.0 is it surreal on a
day-to-day basis still or if you kind of
settled into the fact that you've
changed the planet like you kind of
manifested being Fanus of your own I
tried to keep a low profile when I'm not
at one of these things here and when I
play racquetball a few times a week and
at the YMCA and when I went into hand my
card the lady behind the desk set this
shortly after eating Vinny Warrior fit
can you sign this book for my son
and I was going oh man - my cover's
blown and it's been a little weird since
then the plumber come over and goes
Brinks book with him to get side
vaguely on this subject I went to a
convention last weekend in Niagara Falls
but nobody told me he was Niagara Falls
Canada so I didn't have a passport so I
cook to the border check and they say
well I have this letter I'm supposed to
be going to compo convention oh and I'm
really known for Wolverine and he's
Canadian you know and they let me in and
then on the way back the schmuck on the
other side you know I have this letter I
don't care about a letter oh okay I know
Thanos I was at I mean Hugh Jackman are
the only two that can play the wolverine
immigration card right so I'm back and I
remember this was very near on 9/11 and
of course I was coming back to my
convention it was in Pittsburgh and you
know went through the security and no
problem you know at that time you don't
joke about it at all
and like but you know went through the
scanner didn't set anything off within
the guy he was a little older than I on
I am and you know wanted to see proper
identification
don't argue fine took out my driver's
license showed it to him looks at it
looks at my boarding pass leaves it to
me said I loved your interview on the
avengers DVD and I mean and it's
becoming more commonplace my wife and I
I mean we're celebrating our 30th
wedding anniversary
and I think part of us being so you know
faithful to each other I get recognized
too many places if I'm with another
woman I'm not gonna be hiding I know
there's gonna be somebody out they say
mr. Paris is this your wife closer than
that marriage would be over but it's
amazing now how four guys who worked in
I don't you know privately in our own
studios and or in the studio system
whatever you know working on a home
alone that now we're recognized a part
of it of course of the internet but the
fact that we're news now so my god you
know you're you wouldn't be paying in
all these exorbitant amount of money for
to watch movies or stand on line to buy
the newest tchotchkes that you can buy
on everyone for these little guys hiding
in their little yes to create count
yes what a Chomsky I can picture this
guy none of you on this stage have an
ethnic right to chotchkie's Jesus
Collider we're gonna edit that out right
by by the way were you done all right
are you done all right I have a cold as
you can probably tell I just checked my
backs in at Burbank and this guy says to
me excuse me can I have your autograph
and I thought does he think I'm Ben
Kingsley and I said who do you think I
am he said Joe Rubinstein 100 K and I
signed an autograph and I did a quick
sketch and then his friend popped up
when can I have one too I mean this is
not what you expect in the real world
and you know everything from any
convention every time you walk yeah all
right is there a moment for you Ron no
life is not shaped weren't you
just once rut run what did that kid in
temple of doom now looking to the future
we're about to experience you know phase
four or five and beyond and this giant
Marvel thoughts murders happened I
really and it's it's a silly thing but I
would love a Wolverine of the proper
height as a five foot eight gentleman
I'd like a hidest appropriate Overeem
once you go small you never go back
becoming that they were writing
Wolverine I think that was Chris has
said the first day of vision was Bob
Hoskins right is there a Wolverine you
guys would like now is there like for me
Taryn Hendrickson who played Elton John
recently he's like five seven he's
Farrell was the right height he also
knows Hugh Jackman there's like tips he
could get what Marines 5-2 I'm not I'm
not dead visiting Niagara Falls a brown
suit goes on right so with the change of
comics going digital tangible graphic
novels they're getting in more hands
than ever it's the most accessible I
think comics have ever been how else
have you seen the industry change from
the inside I was the actual comic book
industry different than even like ten
years ago
Jim now all the editors think they're
actually writing and drawing the books
no it's it's a the computer changed the
way we color them corporations buying up
to companies have changed the way the
companies actually operate you know we
some of us been in this business for
forty years and we've seen everything
changed from the first black characters
coming in
I mean just everything you can go down
the list and it's a different world as
far as I'm concerned yeah and what
better and worse because one of the
things that that I don't know if it's
for the better it's just the way things
developed is that now we're caught
almost like a victims of our own success
that there was a time and of course
where you come in with ideas they want
to hear what a new idea they want to
hear a new concept create a new story as
opposed to now with corporate mandating
most of the things that have done in
comics so there's been a creating common
square of manufacturing comics and
sometimes they want to do another book
with the familiar as opposed to
something new that they had to gamble on
because the stakes are so high and you
know I'm not saying it's bad or in
saying it's good but it does make it
different and I do kind of miss the idea
of being able to go in there and come up
with an idea that they haven't heard
before and they said let's take a chance
on it as opposed to the heavy squeezed
Wolverine into the story or can we put
the Batman into the story in order to
guarantee sales as opposed to let the
fans decide what's successful as opposed
to corporate telling you how you should
produce comics that as Jim said we've
been doing it for over four decades we
seem to know what we're doing you
wouldn't have to success if we hadn't
started it
and sometimes you know getting people
giving you advice some of these guys
have never actually read the comics and
they're produced to comic and telling us
how we should be producing the comics
I think I'm retiring at the right time
and thank you Ron keep it down before
internet before FedEx everybody did
comic books lived in the New York City
tri-state area we kind of knew each
other we'd all wind up at the same
parties or bars or whatever it was now
the last thing I did for Marvel several
years ago was six issues of the
Fantastic Four
not only have I never met my editor I've
never even spoken to my editor I got an
email you want to do it yeah okay here's
another issue it's another issue and
then I said I live in LA now I said I'm
going to New York I'd like to say hi no
no no no I mean well I don't even take
it personally I went well you know I
just want a couple to say hi when oh we
don't like people coming up here we like
making stuff over here that's so
specific that's so strange
Ron have you seen things change from
your set yeah I'll take knowledge is
affected yeah I mean so I see as I work
at home like everybody you know in a
studio by myself and oh you get calls me
editors you know working like the
stories I'm working on the books I'm
working on but now I don't get calls
from anybody it's all emails it's all
you know scripts are sent emails to it
so it's like so I don't talk to anybody
now so it's even more quiet than it was
before it's not faster and that
concludes the old couch complaining
about these young whippersnappers say
whatever okay finally begin do
what what's a coot Oh cap lesson at the
end of this interview virologist
so google it what's a Google now we're
also seeing the world change and like
conventions are becoming more as
mainstream as the comics are like a
blogger talk about good manufacturing
versus mainstream but I'm seeing it
start to kind of shift back to comic
books with conventions like this that
are so comic book based is there
anything that you from from the time of
the 70s 80s if you could if you could
fan Osnap what you would bring back is
there something that you would change in
the industry right now to make it the
standard again movies TV comic anything
for me the fact that I like this
convention I like the idea that yes they
have meet yet ever at the expense of the
comics creators where and they like
actually too many shows when you kind of
you know if it's called a comic book
show but sometimes you feel like this is
your party and you're being put into the
kiddie table and then and I think you're
kind of forgetting again and it's it
happens with almost all media when it
become so successful that the people who
were the grunts working there are
sometimes forgotten no no no you
wouldn't be here without us and I like
the idea like this show where I mean
Jimmy J runs a show yes celebrity guests
from the era from films from other media
and the comic guests were all treated
equally the voice actors though the
comic book people the the on-screen
talent that's what I want for more of
the shows as opposed to just a lot of
fans who you know they they say oh we
love Comic Cons but never read a comic
you know I'd like to see that that
feeling of respect with everyone
involved in the field you know and I
think that's it can't be done this show
shows I think it'd still be done but
some shows have just gotten so big that
they basically are a gigantic media
right and I feel lost to them I've been
to a lot of conventions where there's a
green room for the actors the
celebrities who are getting $100,000 a
weekend so apparently can't afford to
buy their lunch and then there's the
comic book people you guys figure it out
and if you die you die we already have
your work thanks for the inspiration
there's a sparkly vampire in the other
room to name names so I personally love
the way you guys built the infinity all
of the the world of infinity is the
depth of the comics and to me that's the
art they inked the words there's literal
depth in every panel of this book and
and one of the my favorite things about
this entire series is all the characters
look different and that's so hard with
team books and that's so hard with
writing characters that voices sound
different and especially in a book that
is most characters how did you guys
collaborate to make the the inks the
colors the dialogue how did it
differentiates all the characters felt
separate basically we didn't collaborate
at all did we he was out in California
I'm in New York George I didn't even
know he was coming in on the project and
the Skippy game of the full strip Jim
had a pretty much all worked out he even
had you know panel suggested Jim's an
artist so of course it's he's got me
stinking fully so when I came into the
project my job is up bring Jim's vision
to fruition but also to add my own
identity to it when I worked with Marv
Marv would give me a living relatively
loose because that working relationship
I had never worked with Jim before so my
job was to do everything that Jim wanted
but do it differently without losing
Jim's [ __ ] and that I mean he succeeded
good it you know I and of course I'm
most of my career doing team books
if I was going to draw Captain America
Captain America I know so I wanted to
look like Jack Kirby over meat of filter
me same thing with all the other
character trying to find the artist who
whose vision of the character resonated
with me and then just filter it to my
stuff so they they all look like
different characters and thankfully then
when Joe came in to ink it Joe has this
blush of realistic inky South which made
the characters look even more lifelike
to me so thank you oh I was gonna say
following George first of all I was
scared but but what was great was joe
was able to kind of unify the art yeah
since he inked at all so you know
whatever differences we have we're kind
of like more you know fight Thanks yeah
so the short answer is we sort of
blundered our way into a classic hey Tim
hey Tim when you wrote the script I know
you care but did you have an artist in
mind did you hope they get somebody did
you ever think I'll call up John bo-sama
and ask him if he wants to take the
money I figured Rama was going to be
carrying on because because he's just
done the the Anna's quest than that and
George literally you came out of left
field I mean yes we have a surprise for
now he's asked us
I took thought that there should have
gone to Ron yeah I mean I was I was not
complaining or anything he's quite an
artist but you know but where'd he come
from
I mean for me I was over committed so
what am i was doing Infinity Gauntlet
deeply in bubbles with war the gods over
at DC and I was writing that and trying
to coordinate it because my I'm pushing
my editor when I'm maternity he's like
to try to coordinate a lot of
substantive effect it might being able
to handle Infinity Gauntlet
so when Tom DeFalco the editor said that
to let Ron finish issue 4 and I can
start an issue 5 I thought you know Ron
really should have been giving this book
to begin with let Ron finish the series
I'll ain't grants cover so they don't
think I left it up in a peak and I was
angry at anybody but I honestly thought
you know where people give me credit you
know I love the way you drew the
Infinity Gauntlet and I was following
the designs these guys here you know I
mean all I did was interpret these are
the guys who did the creating and I got
I was glad when when Ron was able to get
what I thought was properly his hey Ron
where we sleep when we still doing the
Silver Surfer at that point together no
I always wondered how I got this book I
wondered who when you started on my
surfer yeah yeah you know I just
wondered like Brad Anderson was our
editor right for all the thing Craig
yeah Craig yeah yeah yeah I always
wondered how this happened I mean when
you offered me the Avengers annuals so I
remember that you know my first Marvel
job was the Avengers annual two and one
which is where Thanos originally fights
the eventually gives things out over
time right not the sequel thing next in
the next what was the original phone
call line or was their original call
like for this like long how did they
pitch this book like we need a mega
event book invent a new big bad it's
going to change everything like how did
this come to be in the very beginning
well they had the Silver Surfer and
there was a selling well and they talked
me into coming in and writing it and it
started selling better and so they said
at the time that this guy named Michael
Pearlman bought the company and anything
they could do this to soak more money
out of the readership they were gonna do
this is a time where they were every
x-men had his own book practically so
they said well the silver service doing
well let's do some kind of special
project involving the book and I went
how about thinners and they were kind of
hesitant about that at first and they
said well he's the one who's making
books all again so let's do that and we
didn't even get the first book pencil
but I think before they said the advance
sales on this are doing so well let's do
another project and at that point I said
well we'll do B miniseries in this and
they said oh good we'll cross it over
and that's where all the [ __ ] hit the
fan because none of the editors wanted
me to touch their characters at that
time I had a reputation of killing
people and so nobody wanted me to
especially the x-men attorney said no
x-men and so we had a wrestling
negotiate we eventually got that I think
Wolverine and Cyclops and the books went
out and they sold well and the next
thing we did was the infinity war and at
that point they wanted every character
every every editor wanted their book to
crossover or we were having the add
characters we had no idea who they were
there was one called sleepwalker does
anybody remember a sleepwalker yeah -
there may be three people they said he's
got to be in this book so I wrote him in
just walking through this guy in the
background in one panel sleepwalker is
the extra of the marveling out of this
so whose it was a strange little truth
to get to where we actually got movement
was there a moment for any of you during
the making of this book that surprised
you that like it's something like a
moment of inspiration a moment of change
like mid panel that you didn't expect to
come out of your fingers I up the
packaging there's Ron Lim pages there
that was kind of surprising nobody told
me
no I just pages again forbidden no
surprise I make Oh script as I was going
nothing that you know the one thing I'm
most proud of because I got on the book
when I was offered to say I asked how
many characters are gonna be in it is
that all I mean again you can get or in
there you know but again to speak but my
proudest book thing was when wrote the
snap and I mean Jim paces this way I
wanted to do something a little
different so the entire build-up of it
where I I would think like one panel
that a Jim had written I would then
changing it to two or three to kind of
build up momentum and then I don't know
where the inspiration came when I
finally had to snap to suddenly make
into a shadow with every with the snap
effect negative space there's a I was
kind of proud of myself now because that
wasn't in the script I said he snapped
this official the work should wash me to
pleasure is very bad because that baby
was one of those type of thing yeah I
just was such an important event I
wanted to find it to make it even more
intimate but then Jim had done it and
hope that Jim would see that when I and
in the work I didn't just follow blindly
although I would have done well doing
that as welcome again he's a storyteller
but the fact that I wanted to give him a
little more than he wrote because that's
my job I felt and I'm so happy that he
was happy with it too and everyone
commenting on the snap you know and now
that moment is it everyone knows the
snap is like one of the most pop culture
it's like Darth Vader and razón in less
than 15 pages to do it took a
two-and-a-half-hour movie to do
accompany the staff I was done I was
sitting with a friend of mine watching
the premiere and [ __ ] wow what a build
is it is it honey I got that done in
fifteen pages we just had here two and a
half hours watching this build up to
this one moment
was just the start of the series of
course and I didn't know at the time
when I watched infinity Wars that it was
only part that was a part one that they
were going to be doing continuing so I
thought they handed the movie this way
oh my god how depressing but you got to
remember we had 40 years of comic books
before then that we were building up to
now what character in any medium comic
TV film do you love that you don't feel
like gets enough love like I love
chamber from Generation X and no one
knows who that is but is there a
character that you think like 5 foot 2
Wolverine or like an authentic is a
great character you want to be more
mainstream that isn't yet like you
sleepwalker fans a character that you
love that isn't as mainstream like if
you could like promote a character that
to a more mainstream figure thankfully
having drawn everybody that's pretty
much a non-issue for me I can't choose
among my children but one character
which of course no one expected me to do
which despite the fact that it's not the
book that earning all my grade income
although I am earning money on it was to
prove that I can make Wonder Woman work
you know cuz I got it was a book that I
didn't realize after Moulton and Peter's
were no longer double in the book no one
ever volunteered to do that book I was
the first artist to volunteer to do
Wonder Woman and despite the success the
Titus the Infinity Oakland and all the
offshoots and from that the fact that I
went into a party it was actually
a wedding for some French business and
all these female executives coming over
and thanking me for Wonder Woman even
though I didn't create the character but
the fact that she was a character like
there are a lot of characters out there
that people think will never succeed and
that was a personal triumph I think this
might you know um the tycoons everything
else Wonder Woman was the one character
shook because I feel sorry for her and I
did not want her just to languish and
I'm so grateful now that uh patty
Jenkins and the Oh like that whole world
is my favorite compliment of all I mean
you know and that those who were
negative about it cuz no changes I made
that's what they said they changed the
stuff you made in the in the movies that
one I change stuff when I did the comic
but when Lily Martha's grand daughter
came up to me and Phil hey man it's
introduced us and she said you honored
my grandfather that is the best
compliment I will ever take that I met
that Trump small guy I'm very very proud
of that so I'm gonna open up to you guys
now we've got a question cube which is
nothing I've ever used before so
questions you guys have who's got a
question with a throat C and then you
can toss it to whoever else has a
question this is a nice safe toss for
liability I like that Nerf ball game
might say oh hi yes so what are your
thoughts on the sweet Peters Vegas it's
a cube right in the throat so the cosmic
part I mean that's what was so amazing
about what you developed was the cosmic
battle issues four and five when you
know all of a sudden you're now bringing
in the big entities of the universe do
you see that working into the MCU
do you have kind of an idea of where
that might go actually in the first
script that they drafted for the
infinity war all of the cosmic entities
were in there and Marvel Entertainment
said it's too early to end introduce all
these abstract characters that's why
mistress death is not in the thing I
figure after a couple more this guy dr.
Strange's movies will start getting some
of these in there but basically they
said you got to pull out all the really
really cosmic stuff and you know they
have 20 movies they had to fix up and I
think their original script was like 200
pages long which would have been more
than a three hour movie so I think
they'll eventually get into it but
that's why you haven't seen them at this
point yet specifically for Jim since you
had a cameo in endgame since you had to
sorry being able to be a part of the
culmination of these 22 movies and
everything that you guys did with the
actual Infinity Gauntlet saga what was
it like being able to be there and be a
part of the final movie in phase 3 and
in the infinity sock
well the whole experience so far has
been very surreal and when I went down
to work on the movie I expected to be
sitting somewhere in the background
silently while things are going on in
the front instead they handed me a
script as soon as I got in there I
wasn't on the best of terms with Marvel
editorial at this point so I wasn't
expecting nice things but it turned out
that everybody on the set from the
screenwriters to the direct route Joe
Russo's they all wanted to sit there and
tell me everything so I knew just about
everything before a year be a year and a
half before the movie came out and so
I've been having to keep my mouth shut
during that whole time so now I never
shut up
but it's it's been fun it's all been
good so far so my question is for all of
you just wonder if any of you guys
actually worked with or collaborated
with or actually met Stanley and if he
had any influences in your lives and
your careers and things that have
happened with you that's okay I'll start
with my spy Stanley's story I started
off doing cover layouts for other
artists to actually draw like John
bo-sama and Gil Kane and every day I
would get of a set of Xerox and come up
with a sketch out of what I saw in the
Xeroxes and then Stan would come in at
noon and he would look through him
indigo great great great but and he
would take off his glasses he would set
him on the chair and then he would crawl
up onto his desk and he would act out
his stand was a frustrated actor if
nobody's figured that out already and he
would act out how he would want to
figure to be and about one out of every
five times and I would sit here quietly
to watch to see who had happened he
would then get off the desk and sit on
his glasses he would then reach over hit
his intercom which they had back in
those days and he said Holly I did it
again
and she would run in with a new set of
glasses hand up to him take the other
one away and we would go on from there
is the best cameo I've never seen that's
amazing oh I never worked with Stan but
obviously influenced by his work
obviously from acting Ron is very
succinct shortest name among us and
lives up to it my sad story was like I
had just finished and they just printed
my first Fantastic Four and I
and I also credit a lot of the success
that the great anchor Joe synod who had
been inking is fantastic for for so many
years on so many different artists have
to Jack Kirby is as well and I got a
call from Holly Stan's secretary saying
that Stan wanted to meet me and of
course the second I was born raised
Catholic side being asked to have a with
the Pope so I went over and go stand so
am i working fantastic for looked at the
credit here expecting to see Bruce Emma
over Mitas name I never saw this name
before and called me and said yeah as
long as you're working here you're
always going to have it as long as I'm
alive you always got to work it here and
Stan gave me my first raise and in
addition to that I was so awestruck with
the idea
I'm meeting Stan Lee I actually bought
books for Stan's a sign and a business
meeting that he was asking me to come to
and oh and I just got so tickled by the
fact that you know this was Stan never
mr. Lee that I that I was in a job the
head guy the guy who you know that
everything has to go through you call
him by his first name it was a wonderful
friendly experience and I had seen Stan
- obviously many times since then and
Lord knows I changed a lot in the from a
20 year old to a 65 year old and Stan
always remembers me and one of the great
joys of Stan is that one of the last
things he said to me at a convention was
I love comics I obviously always love
comics but I also love the fans and I've
always liked to be with the fans and you
know be entertaining and Stan said
you're like my nephew that's what I
that's what I want you're like it's what
I always wanted at the relationship that
people should see that comics are fun
and if we don't enjoy it how can we
expect them to enjoy it and so when he
died I saw I actually cried figured I
just lost my uncle Stan so that's my
staff
hi I was working up at Marvel when I was
19 on mr. Garland's avengers annual I
think I was in a side office because it
was the summer and it was hot in that
air-conditioning so I'm working and all
of a sudden the door bursts open and
Stanley walks in and I'm just like oh my
god it's Stanley and they were doing
these black-and-white comic books back
then with painted covers so Stan came in
with a board with one of these bed made
the covers right so it goes in he puts
it on the floor to look at it he does
this and puts his elbow right into my
ink and I think to myself well that was
a short career I mean I enjoyed it for
what it was that I was hoping for our
little Borland Jeopardy but you know and
then and so I'm going oh I either don't
say a word and a couple of hours from
now he goes hey or I do say a word and
he fires me on the spot and I go mr. Lee
you put your elbow to my aim get away
bad happens all the time at least my
glasses are still in one right bracket
and then I stepped on his glasses
where's the tube of powder it is cosmic
you this is a little rare
you're talking into it but it's a cute
this is for all four of you even the
panel guy since sans God who do you want
to be the new cameo besides yourselves
would you want Deadpool or Wolverine or
would you want to be the next Stan Lee
cameo gothic Roy Thomas would kill to do
this and would kill any of us and try to
get in there because I I love looking
for Stan I love looking for all of you
guys and I'm hoping that George Prest
makes an appearance and cw's infinite
price infinite right dizzy my luck I'll
be one of the people killed in Infinite
Crisis 39 you're Perez was doing both DC
and marvel at the same time with crisis
and Infinity Gauntlet would be cool to
see him do a dual cameo again those are
that's decision made by other people I
know my mask I'd be flattered and I'm
not asked Mike goes on I'm fine you know
there was a TV show and HBO called
entourage and the head in episode said
it's ending Comic Con and they'd bought
my artwork for it and asked me if I
wanted to be in the show
it's the dullest thing in the world to
be on a TV show and hours and hours and
a make-believe studio know that but once
they also bought my artwork for the Big
Bang Theory in the episode where stands
signing in a comic book store like
that's ever gonna happen right and I'm
I'm standing out in front in the line
waiting for Stan's autograph and I'm
standing behind two of the stars of the
show and they yelled cut and they put a
tall guy between me and the other guys
cuz I look too much like those guys
your cameos already out there yeah this
is a cliche answer but for me the
opening comic panels of a Marvel movie I
see these guys like the panel's flipping
is always in the comics to me so my
answer is like this is the world of
comics so it's re vibe represented so as
long as that happens I'm happy
where's the cube we got time for one
more
somebody stole the cubes yeah it was
gone so rec whoever is the most excited
there's up I see a hand
we got excitement we got two hands we
have movement I am out you lost an eye
okay you had your chance you missed the
catch yeah humble your cut hello
alright so what is your favorite comic
book creator of all time who did you get
hurt okay I'm sorry I can't choose among
my parents Jack but also Neal Adams
Curt's want it just way way too many I
mean we were all a product of a mixture
of influences and yeah Jack brought
excitement he was good to me like a like
a Salvador Dali of comics but then I
also respected like Curt Swan at the
Norman Rockwell of comics they were more
sedate so there are a lot of people out
there a Jack Kirby two-page spread was
wondrous and panoramic and there's no
denying he's probably the greatest comic
artists ever but when I look at Joe
Kubert at arson fighting a gorilla with
that fur flying and the slashes across
the body that would take my breath away
thank you guys so very much let's give
it up for these Titans of Mad Titans